um we're about to start live streaming
now
uh just a moment
very distinctive hat marcus
okay i'd like to welcome everyone to
today's infrastructural services
committee 21 december
i'm going to start with uh
we have zoom attendees which is mrs
barney koote
welcome um
i don't see her up there yet
but she will come
and we have apologies from councillor
abbott can i have someone please move
chicago group council adelaide secretary
council lewis put that all those in
favor aye all right yes that is we've
just got a technical hatch
right
moved by ludlow seconded by lewis thank
you
it's fine the majority approved
yep
keep going right
okay we're going to start with
the only thing on the agenda which is
the code of practice for land
development and subdivision
infrastructure
and speaking to that will be
welcome jeremy
have you got a microphone up there
where's that we portable
where's the
just over here
[Music]
and hayden welcome as well
hello here we go here we go
okay
everyone
uh
i take it the report in front of you as
read i'll just highlight the following
quick points uh this is brought to
council when adopted for consultation on
the 23rd of november and consultation
plan took place between 24 november and
10 december and is now complete the main
portion of that consultation was a
webinar we held on the 2nd of december
from this consultation there are no
changes proposed to the practice note
we'll have to invite any questions
that people may have
okay what would you what would you say
are there significant points
that um
that that this refers to
jeremy
yep so this is really just around um
and consistency around providing
connections for subdivisions at the time
of
subdivision um and also a little bit
around stormwater design criteria
really to bring it in line with good
practice that
we want through our invocable
right now that makes sense uh other
questions
counselor sopher thanks mr chair it's
not really a question but since it's in
the report i just want to say i see the
full bylaws going to be reviewed next
year
and we're exploring working with south
and district council on that i just
wanted to say congratulations and
i hope that goes well but
congratulations to staff on doing that i
think it will be great if we're able to
um
to work together on on that review yep
thank you
right
ms scott
um just because um i'm a bit challenged
in this area
but
on page
20
where it talks about
the icc datum
is it seriously a hundred
mean c level here
so um i get like i can address that um
just for a clarity point that that
document was included for the context of
the bylaw review that we'll undertake
next year so that's not practice note
that is the main point for discussion
but
the datum is uh because we do have
infrastructure below
sea level at zero we don't end up with
negative
ah um and it's
it's one of these arbitrary things but
we as engineers and surveys love doing
things like that
thank you i just
yep
datum stuff um confuses my brain but a
hundred meters below means sea level
it's panicked me thank you yep
right
further questions
and we can go to the
recommendations uh the recommendations
are that we receive the report
uh we receive the summary of submissions
and email submissions
and the we adopt the proposed practice
note and i've moved secretly
i'm going to put those three
recommendations all those in favor aye
against
that is done thank you very much thank
you
guys thank you um and i'll now declare
uh
the infrastructure meeting is over
the next meeting is risk and assurance
if we could just have a few moments i
will see where the chair is how he's
placed
short
foreign
right
thank you
i'm just wondering where it is
see through musical chairs up here is it
i i'm not exactly
certain
um slightly
uh um
but how do you describe it clear sid of
the pants uh stuff this afternoon uh as
we try and move
into the risk and assurance
committee meeting in fact
what i'd like to do in opening the
meeting
is do the pro forma stuff which is
absolutely important
but then
i will start talking about the actual
agenda
so this is the meeting of the
sorry the extraordinary meeting the risk
and insurance committee
for the 21st of december
i understand at this point we will be
live streamed
and so i welcome those that are doing so
and indeed i think members of the public
that are here today
i would uh
like to note that i think we have a
person
attending by way of zoom
i'd like to move to apologies i have an
apology for
uh councillor abbott
do i have any other
in counsellor scout
and also perhaps greatest acknowledge
the late apology lateness for
ross jackson
ross probably will be here at 3 but
i know he was under some pressure
um any other apologies have been none
i'll put that motion do i have a second
to please thank you darren
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
those against it's kerry thank you very
much
i haven't been informed of any
member of the public requesting to take
advantage of
public forum
on the agenda there are two major late
items
we can't deal with the first one yet
which is the annual report
um
and
when
as i ultimately do move into px i would
like michael to brief us where were at
because it will form part of
the rest of our day i hope
but i'd like to move
then to item six which is the major late
item to be received
public excluded
which is
uh share bolt versus icc
so i'd like to move from the chair that
we accept this major late item
for the reason that it stated that the
item came to hand after
the agenda was
published
do i have a second to please
thank you becks i'll put that motion all
in favor please say aye
those against
that's carried thank you
um
right
item seven which is just moving through
the agenda is one where i need to then
move to number eight which is that uh
from the chair again i
will move that we go into public
excluded
with thank you peter with the exception
exception of jeff and lindsey to remain
as our external governance
appointees i've moved that
peter thank you you've seconded that
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
those against
it's carried
i wonder if we could invite our other
external
friends too
you